on the eve of the 1876 presidential
election police foiled a plan to rob
abraham lincoln's corpse from his tomb
in stealing lincoln's body thomas
crogwell looks at the ransom plot and
how the thieves were stopped he talks
about his book from the president
abraham lincoln hotel in springfield
illinois this is about 45 minutes
this afternoon's speaker is the author
of stealing lincoln's body published by
the harvard university press
and actually released today
he has written more than a dozen books
on history religion and popular culture
his articles have appeared in the wall
street journal the new york times the
american spectator
emmy magazine
and inside the vatican
he has also been a guest on
cnn the bbc
the discovery channel
and the international catholic cable
network ewtn
he writes out of his home in bethel
connecticut
please join me in welcoming dr thomas
crawwell
[Applause]
thank you john
it's a it's especially pleasant for me
to be here today because um
the two gentlemen who are up at the dais
with us who were such an enormous help
to me when i was researching this book
uh first of all
dr wayne temple a gentleman who
could find anything i was looking for
and my friend john austin who when i
approached him about using his archive
said oh we don't have anything that
you'd need
and a day and a half and god knows how
many file boxes later
so i'm very i'm very pleased to be here
today with all of you
uh
if
the lincoln monument association had had
their way back in 1865 we would not have
gone out to the cemetery this morning
for the ceremony
we would have gone to the site of the
state capitol
because
the gentleman of the monument
association wanted to bury abraham
lincoln in a place that was prominent
that was in the middle of town that was
going to draw a lot of attention bring
in a lot of tourists new business
possibly new residents
in this in this regard they ran up
against mary lincoln
when lincoln died
there were really three contenders for
his burial site one was washington dc
underneath the capital rotunda there was
a vault a crypt that had been prepared
for george washington it was never used
because george and martha wanted to be
buried together at mount vernon a second
runner-up was chicago because the
lincolns had discussed retiring to
chicago at the end of the second term
but they had no real ties to the city so
that was ruled out pretty quickly
the capital crypt was out of the
question because there was only room for
lincoln and mary was not going to let
him go any place that she was not going
to go
so the logical solution obviously was
springfield their home
by coincidence the governor of illinois
richard oglesby was in washington at the
time of the assassination and when he
found out that springfield was the
destination he was simply delighted and
and wired home and within a matter of
hours they had the most distinguished
men in town
including the lincoln's banker jacob
bunn and mary's cousin john todd stewart
coming together
creating an organization with the idea
of raising money and selecting a site
for the tomb uh the selecting the site
for the tomb was what got them into
trouble
mary lincoln wanted
oak ridge
and she wanted it for a couple of
reasons first of all the story of
lincoln wanted to be buried in a quiet
place and oak ridge was decidedly quiet
two to three miles outside of town
secondly there was it was what was part
of what was called at the time the rural
cemetery movement this had started up in
the 1830s in in boston mount auburn was
the very first rural cemetery
the purpose of a rural cemetery was to
get away from the crowded unsightly
burial grounds and churchyards that were
inside cities and create a place that
was part botanical garden part outdoor
art museum a beautiful restful place for
the dead but also a place that families
would be pleased to go and visit on
weekends um bringing picnic lunches was
perfectly
acceptable at the at the time and these
places were truly lovely every town
after the success of mount auburn in the
1830s every city in town with any
pretensions to gentility wanted their
own rural cemetery about 1850
springfield got oak ridge and the
lincolns were actually among the
dignitaries who attended the dedication
now the site that the lincoln monument
association wanted was was called the
mather block it was a piece of property
where the state capitol is now it was
owned by a widow named hannah mather it
was the only house her house was the
only one on the block
groves of trees a garden it was a lovely
beautiful place
it was the highest point in town
you could see it from the trains that
were passing in and out of springfield
it would be very easy for for tourists
to get to the lincoln tomb there if they
went out to oak ridge they were going to
have to take them out by trolleys or by
carriage it was it it just seemed a
logistical nightmare and so they decided
to ignore what mary wanted and they
actually sent a crew of excavators and
stone masons out to the mather block to
start building a little temporary crypt
now when mary lincoln back in washington
heard that her friends and neighbors and
relatives were ignoring her wishes she
had a secretary of war stanton sent a
telegram saying expressly not to the
mather block but out to oak ridge and in
this point robert lincoln backed up his
mother and said his own telegram saying
that we demand that the family's wishes
be respected so they slammed on the
brakes
by this point really the the little
temporary tomb of the mather block was
was done right down to the ornamental
urns flanking flanking the door and the
lincoln train is getting closer and
closer
but they stopped and they sent another
work crew out to oak ridge to tidy up
the receiving vault which is down in the
ravine at the bottom of the hill below
the lincoln monument to prepare that for
lincoln and that's where he and willie
were placed on the day of the funeral
and that's where uh
the the doors were locked the key was
given to robert lincoln he passed it
along to his cousin john todd stewart
and they started the ball rolling for
building a lincoln monument or so
the lincoln family thought because after
the funeral
uh the national monument association
apparently people who could not take a
hint
leaked to the springfield newspapers
that they were really going to bury him
in the mather block after all
well mary read the springfield
newspapers
so now she's delivered an ultimatum she
did not simply want a family tomb
anymore she wanted something dynastic
she wanted a tomb that was going to be
large enough for the president for her
for their sons for their sons wives the
wives of their surviving sons and for
any grandchildren that she might have
she wanted the whole thing they actually
at one point the governor and some of
the other members of the monument
committee went up to chicago she was she
was living there they were going to try
and make a personal appeal to her
to let them use the mather block not
only would she refuse to see them but
she sent robert to the train station
telling them it's pointless go home
and so finally they did cave in and they
they built they built the tomb out at
oak ridge now we flash forward about 10
years
and there's a man in chicago
named big jim connealy and big jim
connealy
led a counterfeiting ring he was an
irish immigrant uh he had been in and
out of jail for passing counterfeit
money
in spite of his name big jim was
actually small potatoes in terms of
the crime world of in illinois we know
he had one other interest he was a
silent partner in a saloon on the near
west side of chicago a place called the
hub
it was his other partner was a man named
terence mullen also an irish immigrant
terence mullen was 28 years old he had
no criminal record but his saloon was a
hangout
for counterfeiters
and
one of his cronies was a man named jack
hughes jack hughes passed counterfeit
money and he had also
well let's call him the underachiever of
counterfeiters because back in
philadelphia
while other counterfeiters would produce
five dollar ten dollar twenty dollar
bills
jack hughes produced counterfeit nickels
poor quality counterfeit nickels because
he was constantly being arrested in
philadelphia and finally the town got
too hot for him and he moved out to
chicago
now
although big jim kennealy was not a big
deal he did have one very important
asset he had one of the finest engravers
counterfeit engravers in the country
working for him a man named benjamin
boyd boyd was from cincinnati he was the
son of an engraver a legitimate engraver
his father had apprenticed him when he
was a kid to a legitimate engraver but
sometime in his late teens he started
running into
counterfeit engravers
and by the time he was 21 he had he had
engraved his first counterfeit plate and
that was the end of his legitimate
career he never engraved another
christening cup or wedding ring
uh he was he went to work for keneally
um and they made a fortune his
stuff was of such
high quality
that uh
the money just kept rolling in
about this time
there was a secret service detective
named patrick tyrell also an irish
immigrant
and patrick tyrell
was after benjamin boyd the in these
days the secret service was not designed
to protect the president the secret
service was the law enforcement wing of
the u.s treasury and it was to fight
counterfeiting um
there had always been counterfeiting in
america in the in the 17th century the
indians used to pass off counterfeit
wampum to the white settlers
but there was never a national currency
in the united states until 1862 when
abraham lincoln approved the first
national currency for the union um
because the the cost of the civil war it
was not practical to pay in gold and
silver anymore
this was great news for the for the
local counterfeiters they just
wired up their presses and by 1865
the estimate is that about half of the
currency circulating in the north was
counterfeit
hence the secret service being invented
to
track down the counterfeiters
boyd tracked down or not buoyed
kenneally tracked down boyd
to uh
the town he was working out of up in the
northwest corner of illinois he arrested
him he found so much evidence in the
house that that it took them all day to
collect it counterfeit plates
counterfeit money um counterfeit tools
for engraving counterfeit plates it was
it was a gold mine there was so much
there that when boyd went to trial he
was not only found guilty he was
sentenced to 10 years in juliet
now with boyd gone connelly's
supply of good quality top quality
counterfeit money has now dried up
he can still get counterfeit money but
he has to buy it from middlemen which is
cutting into his profits not only that
it's raising the risk because this stuff
isn't of
benjamin boyd caliber
now
he's wondering what can he do
to get benjamin boyd out of the big
house in joliet
he has no political influence
so he starts
the little brain starts turning and he
comes up with an idea of how to pressure
the governor of illinois to release
benjamin boyd and his plan is
to steal the body of abraham lincoln and
hold it for ransom
it's a breathtaking
scheme
and no one knows
where he came up with this idea
there was body snatching but you sold
the body to a medical school so they
could dissect the corpses
the idea of holding a corpse for ransom
really
not on the radar yet
so he goes up to chicago to
his friends at the hub and he sits down
with terence mullen and jack hughes and
he explains to them what he wants them
to do he wants them to go
down to springfield steal the body put
it in a wagon put the coffin in a wagon
and drive it up to the indiana dunes
and bury it in the sand there and then
and this is really the genius part he's
going to get a message of what they've
done to boyd in the prison in joliet and
boyd is going to approach the warden
and then the warden is supposed to tell
the governor that if they pardon
if he pardons boyd and hands over two
hundred thousand dollars in cash because
as long as you're asking
then they'll get the body of abraham
lincoln back safe and unharmed
the the genius part of this of course is
that it keeps canelli mullen and
hughes's names entirely out of this
proposition um boyd is handling the
arrangements the negotiations all by
himself
mullen and hughes sign on the 200 000
payday i'm sure had something to do with
it
and canali thinks this is a done deal
and he gets up and he leaves the saloon
and that's when the trouble started
because sitting in the middle of this
saloon mullen and hughes start saying
out loud neither of us have any grave
robbing experience how are we going to
rob this how are we going to steal this
body and at the end of the bar is a
regular named louis swaggles who
overhears them and walks over and says
i'm the boss body snatcher of chicago
so they invited to sit down
and they now swaggles had become had
started coming in about three months
previous and mullen was always a little
shy around strangers because of course
his saloon was a hangout for criminals
but swagels had ingratiated himself into
the crowd with all of these stories of
his criminal exploits especially with
two
accomplices who he said their names were
billy brown and somebody else named
frenchy
and after three months he was he was
part of the family
so when they invited him in to the
little circle here uh
they just were completely candid of what
they were going to do they were going to
steal the body of abraham lincoln and
hold it for ransom and suegos was
stunned but he obviously didn't want
you know to
put them off so we sat there and talked
with them and we can imagine they
probably had a few drinks and then he
got up and he walked out the door of the
saloon and he turned left and walked
across town and went directly
to the office of patrick carroll
louis suegels was a paid informant of
the secret service
now when tyrell hears about this plot to
steal lincoln's body
he's horrified
but he's also a little bit
career-minded so the first thing that he
does is he sends a telegram to his
superior in washington saying i know
this is not strictly a counterfeiting
case
but since counterfeiters are involved i
would really like to do this he did not
want to hand this over obviously to to
another law enforcement agency this is a
career building opportunity and then he
went to see robert lincoln robert
lincoln was living in chicago at the
time with his wife and children he had a
law practice there
robert lincoln sent a telegram too he
sent it down to his his mother's cousin
john todd stewart in springfield to warn
him that there was a possibility of of
tomb desecration and
thank the good lord
the secret service required in these
days this is 1876 required that the the
the chiefs of all the individual
districts had to file a daily report
essentially a diary of all their
activities and patrick carroll
was
honest and hardworking and a man of
tremendous integrity and a man who just
loved paperwork
he we have
preserved in the national archives in
college park maryland
the entire
account from the day he heard it from
swaggles until
well after
the guys were in jail
day by day he wrote a detailed account
of every single thing that he did
involved in in this in this case it's an
absolute gold mine and a historian's
dream i'll probably never run into
anything like this again
and so anyway they start planning
swagels is going to keep the secret
service
up to date on all of the plans
mullen and hughes decide that they want
to pull off the job very quickly hughes
is especially eager to get the ball
rolling because he's pointing out to
them this is october it's chicago it
could start snowing
and he said that he didn't want to have
to dig both sand and snow at the indiana
dunes so stealing the body of abraham
lincoln doesn't trouble him but the man
draws the line at shoveling snow
they they pick as the day that they're
going to do this on november 7th it's
election day this is the hayes tilden
presidential election
and they figure election day is perfect
because
nobody will notice strangers in
springfield on that day because all of
the farmers are going to be coming in to
vote and nobody's going to go out to the
cemetery to make a nocturnal visit to
the tomb because everybody's going to be
gathered at the telegraph offices
waiting for the returns to come in
and swaggles passes this along to tyrol
tyrol is feeling that he really needs
reinforcement so he borrows a couple of
pinkerton detectives and on
the evening of november 6th
um they're all going to take
the tr the overnight train from chicago
to springfield and i mean literally they
were all on the same train the
counterfeiters got into the first car
and the secret service got into the last
car
and they all came down here together and
actually stayed in hotels one block away
the counterfeiters were at the saint
charles and the secret service was at
the saint nicholas
and the first thing patrick terrell did
when he got to springfield was he went
out to the tomb to meet john carroll
power who was the custodian john carroll
power was a kentucky born man just like
abraham lincoln and also jefferson davis
uh and he had tried for a time
making a living as a sod buster out in
kansas had no success um decided to
relocate to springfield because he was
an ardent supporter of abraham lincoln
and he wanted to live in the hometown of
his hero so he came here um
became quite a good amateur historian um
talk to the historians and archivists in
in this town and they'll tell you about
what what a
wonderful work he did he cr he found
he had access to primary documents that
are long gone sadly he wrote a biography
of lincoln he wrote an account of the
funeral he wrote the first history of
the first settlers of the county um a
busy guy and in 1874 after the lincoln
monument was dedicated he was hired as
the first custodian they paid him fifty
dollars a month
so carol goes out explains what he wants
to do power gives him a tour of the
place and they decide that they're going
to have a stakeout at the tomb that
night
and about six o'clock tyrell and the
pinkerton detectives go out take a
carriage out to oak ridge and power is
waiting for them
um
it's a cold november night but they had
steam heat in memorial hall which is the
the vestibule uh the what's now the
entry vestibule to the tomb
so they go in and they decide they're
going to take off their boots because
they're afraid that
the sound of of the heels of the boots
on the marble floor will echo into the
back tomb chamber so they're standing
there in their stocking feet they turn
up the steam and they turn off the
lights and they wait and they wait for
two hours because mullen and hughes and
swaggles have decided to walk out
now
the way the tomb was designed in 1874
by a man named larkin mead who was a new
england boy who'd studied architecture
over in florence
there was no direct connection from
memorial hall to the tomb chamber in the
back like you had today today you can do
this nice little circle it keeps the
traffic moving through the tomb
the way mead had built it there was
memorial hall and those galleries were
there but they were dead ends and
my hunch is that because mary wanted a
tomb for three generations worth of
lincoln that mead might have felt that
he was going to lose too much burial
space
this is just a guess
so
dead end galleries the only way to get
to the burial chamber was you had to
walk out the front door walk all the way
around to the back which is about 120
feet
and they unlocked the steel door and you
you went into the tomb chamber they
called it by the way at the time the
catacomb even though catacombs are
underground
um but this is another little part of of
late 19th century
trends the catacombs have been
rediscovered in rome in the mid 19th
century and it created a sensation um
including the things like like novels
for example quovatas and last days of
pompeii and
so you now have abraham lincoln the
martyred president
in a sarcophagus an altar-shaped tomb
and you're putting him in a place that
you call
the catacomb and so you just reinforce
all all of the sacred character that
people were had started imposing on
lincoln and the assassination pretty
much from the moment that he died
the criminals get to the cemetery they
make a beeline for the back door of the
tomb and the only thing between them and
the coffin is a single padlock there was
no security in oak ridge there was no
night watchman there was no sexton or
custodian living at the site uh
and there there was only this padlock
and so now you have these three
criminals standing up in front of the
padlock and none of them can pick a lock
so they took out a file
and they had to actually cut through it
it took half an hour for them to saw
through
the hasp of of of the lock and they were
inside they one of the one of the
counterfeiters wanted to smash the lid
and and swagel said no let's see if we
can pry it off and he stuck a crowbar
underneath it again talk about poor
security they had sealed the lid of the
sarcophagus with plaster of paris
it crumbled right away
they lifted it off leaned it against the
walls at the back of the tomb where the
vaults are for the family now
and
the the fit was so tight the coffin
inside the sarcophagus that they
couldn't get any purchase to lift it out
so then they took a large saw and they
cut off the foot of the marble
sarcophagus and they started to pull
well it was a cedar box wrapped in lead
and weighed about 500 pounds
and they couldn't get it out they got it
out about 15 inches
and
it wouldn't budge anymore
at this point swagel says he's going to
go out to the gate because they they
have a an accomplice coming the guy with
the wagon a man named nealy he's going
to go out to the gate look for neely and
come back and maybe four of them can
lift this
of course he doesn't go out to the gate
he goes immediately to the door of
memorial hall
tips off
carol and the other detectives and they
come running out and terrell is so
excited that he didn't even bother to
put his boots back on he's running in
his stocking feed and one of the
pinkerton detectives that he's borrowed
for the night a man named george hay is
so nervous that something's going to go
wrong that he [ __ ] his pistol while
he's running
and of course the hammer slips
and the gun goes off and in the silence
of the cemetery at nine o'clock at night
that single shot sounded like a cannon
and by the time they got to the back
door by the time they got to the tomb
chamber and tyra was screaming
surrender give yourselves up
and nobody answers
and he steps inside and strikes a match
and they're all gone you know they've
bolted um this was not a problem really
because
mullin and hughes made a b line right
back to chicago right back to the hub
where tyro picked him up a couple days
later um
by the way an interesting little
sideline about about the hub
the hub is not the type of victorian
saloon that we see in the movies there
was no gleaming mahogany and polished
brass spittoons and stained glass
windows uh it was it was grimy it was
dingy it probably had no more than one
or two tables um and its only
ornament
ironically was a white plaster bust of
abraham lincoln
now tyrell is pretty much out of the
picture at this point um but for john
carroll power the headaches are just
starting because he now has a vandalized
tomb
and the next day like every other day
tourists are going to show up at the
lincoln tomb and they're going to want a
tour and
the place is trashed
and
there's another issue once this gets
into the press and it got into the press
the very next day
what if there are copycat grave robbers
out there who are more competent than
mullen and hughes and come back and
actually do manage to steal the body of
abraham lincoln
john todd stewart was having the same
types of headaches he complained of
insomnia and the two of them decided the
only thing to do was to move
the coffin someplace where nobody would
look for it and they thought that would
be the basement of of the tomb so they
got a bunch of men from the lincoln
monument association who whose
ages ranged from 60
to 69.
power at 57 was the kid in the group
and somehow
these guys actually managed to lug this
500 pound coffin out of out of the tomb
chamber around to the front and
downstairs into the basement actually
uh john todd stewart hurt himself and
was
in bed as an invalid for months
afterwards and by the time they got it
down they were too exhausted to try to
even dig a grave so they just left it
and power came back the next morning to
start to dig a grave well
oak ridge has a high water table
and everywhere he stuck a shovel
water kept bubbling up
and the idea of lowering the body of
abraham lincoln into some muddy hole was
just
beyond beyond question so what he did
instead was he took all this mildewed
lumber and and debris construction
debris that was left over when they had
built the tomb and he buried the coffin
under all of this garbage
and back upstairs in the meantime they
had rearranged the um
the sarcophagus and and cemented the
foot of the sarcophagus back in place
and put the lid back on so and whenever
people came in the next nine months um
power talked to them as if lincoln was
inside the sarcophagus
he might have stayed he might have still
been there
except for
something that happened in the summer of
1877 larkin mead came back he was ready
to install some of those dramatic
sculptural groups that are around the
base of the obelisk the
army the infantry the navy the artillery
and the cavalry
um
so that meant there was going to be a
lot of workmen around there were going
to be strangers around the tomb they
were going to be in the cellar they were
going to be all over the place and and
power didn't want them to just stumble
on the coffin accidentally so
he decided he would take the foreman of
the work crew aside and tell him what
was down there and he revealed the great
secret and made the man swear he would
not tell us all and the man swore oaths
up and down and within 24 hours
everybody in springfield knew where
abraham lincoln's body was
so power is now not only angry but
humiliated
and he decides he's he's really going to
have to find a place to hide it this
time he goes and brings in friends who
are in their 30s and these are all
ordinary guys um
bank tellers
hotel clerks
shopkeepers you know nothing
the
the just ordinary working middle class
men
and they meet at the tomb in the middle
of the night and they just start digging
all over the place until finally they
found a dry corner
and they could get it down so that it
would cover
they could cover the coffin with about
two to three inches of dirt that was as
far as they could go without hitting the
water table again
and then they took
a solemn oath among themselves that they
would never reveal the location of
abraham lincoln's grave and one of them
actually went back to his store that
night and thought you know if we were
all in
a carriage accident and everybody's
wiped out nobody would know where
lincoln's body was and they'd open the
sarcophagus and it'd be empty so we
actually wrote a little document and
drew a map and he locked it away in his
vault in his store
so the so that if anything happened
people would eventually be able to find
the body of abraham lincoln
this is a remarkable group of guys and
they decided to call themselves the
lincoln guard of honor and the
interesting thing is that to the public
they said that they were going to do
what we did this morning which was
called commemorative ceremonies on
lincoln's birthday and on the death day
and it was exactly like it was this
morning there was a benediction there
was music there were speeches um
the union veterans were there
this is
classic now
we would think
the smartest thing to do would be to get
a really good security system or at
least hire a night watchman but
in the 19th century
the idea of forming a fraternal
organization or forming a secret society
was second nature the the 1870s 1880s
was the high water mark of fraternal
organizations in the in this country
it's estimated that if there were about
32 million men in the united states at
this period about 5.5 million of them
belong to at least one such organization
the knights of pythius the masons the
odd fellows
there was and new ones were cropping up
all the time
there was one group that called
themselves the supreme tribe of ben hur
they were inspired by general lew
wallace's novel ben hur
and their uh their most their most
sacred ceremony in their lodge hall was
a reenactment of the chariot race
so the the lincoln guard of honor made
perfect sense but the interesting thing
about the lincoln guard of honor is that
unlike the supreme tribe of ben hur and
the odd fellows is that membership was
closed they were not recruiting new
people
and
also this was a secret society that
really had the secret worth keeping and
they never revealed it
they kept that body absolutely secure um
and the only person they told it to was
to robert lincoln who was genuinely
touched by by this this act of devotion
and these were strangers to him he
didn't know who they were
and in 1882 when mary lincoln died after
the funeral ceremony was over robert
lincoln asked
these gentlemen to move his mother's
coffin and bury it downstairs in the
basement next to abraham lincoln so she
was in a shallow grave too
and might have stayed there except for
something that happened in 1900 the tomb
literally started to fall apart
you remember the high water table well
lark and mead apparently ignored it
and
the building started to collapse and the
engineers at the state of illinois
called in
said
dismantle the whole thing sink deeper
foundations and and rebuild and so
that's what they decided to do the
question of course now is what are you
going to do with all the lincoln bodies
um all of the boys are there except
robert um one of the grandchildren is
there robert's son jack he's died since
then
and they built something
suitable for a pharaoh they dug
where our
chairs were today very near there they
dug an enormous pit in the ground lined
it with thick concrete walls lowered the
coffins into the into this pit covered
it with massive concrete slabs that they
had to have cranes to put in place and
then raised
a giant earth mound on top of it and
that's where all of the lincolns were
for the next 14 months while they
dismantled and rebuilt
the uh the lincoln monument by the way
they also decided to add 15 feet to the
obelisk because in the original
structure it was a little stumpy it
looks much more impressive now
robert lincoln
sent a message down saying that he he
was not going to attend the final burial
and he wanted no civic ceremony he
wanted no religious ceremony he wanted
it to be kept as as private as possible
uh the surviving members of the lincoln
guard of honor showed up of course
uh they had a group of witnesses about
28 witnesses various dignitaries and
from around town um
and it was so unceremonious we have a
photograph of
the members of the excavation crew
serving as lincoln's pallbearers
bringing the coffin into the tomb and so
in ceremonies that they hadn't even
taken their hats off while they were
doing it
then there was one other final witness
who was going to come one of the members
of the lincoln guard was a man named
joseph lindley and he had a 13 year old
son named fleetwood fleetwood was in
school that day and that morning a note
arrived in fleetwood's classroom for his
teacher
and it was a note please excuse
fleetwood and tell him to hop on his
bicycle and pedal over to the oak ridge
as fast as he can and with all the
enthusiasm of any 13 year old boy who's
been led out of school early
fleetwood was on the bicycle and heading
to the cemetery like a shot
came so fast that he actually left off
his bicycle at the tomb door and rolled
the bicycle into memorial hall
and inside was his father and all these
other witnesses and the coffin of
abraham lincoln on two wooden saw horses
and the kid realized what he was about
to see because there were two other
individuals in the memorial hall that
day there were two springfield plumbers
leon hopkins and his brother-in-law
charles willey they were there to cut
the lead sheath
there was going to be a final
identification of the remains of abraham
lincoln robert lincoln had not
authorized this the lincoln guard had
taken it upon themselves to do this
and the plumbers cut through the sheath
and they raised the lid and everybody
crowded around and there was abraham
lincoln perfectly preserved
the wart on the cheek the tuft of beard
on the chin the unruly black hair
and
fleetwood said later that he wasn't
frightened at the time but for the next
six months he had lincoln nightmares
and now that the now that the
identification had been completed they
closed the lid resealed the coffin um by
the way just a little tangential thing
leon hopkins the plumber had been
promised three bucks for the job and he
failed to submit an invoice and it was
not until 1939
that everybody figured out the error so
he received 22.49
compound interest
for the job that he did back in 1901.
uh
robert lincoln had given very specific
instructions on how he wanted his father
to be buried this was the last burial
and he wanted it 100 percent secure
they put the coffin of lincoln inside
a steel cage and they lowered the steel
cage into a 10-foot deep vault and then
they poured wet cement over it
and that's where that's where lincoln is
today this was not an original idea um
robert lincoln had picked it up
from uh
the pullman's um mr pullman of the
pullman
palace car frame was the became the most
hated man in america
that was his his the title that he
earned in the 1890s after he put down
the strike in a way that was so
obnoxious that even the president of the
united states thought that he was he was
way out of line um and
towards the end of his life pullman was
afraid that all of these people across
the country who hated him some of them
might come and try to desecrate his body
so he had his coffin put in um
a cage made of railroad ties
and lowered into the ground and then the
wet cement on on top
the uh
always colorful general ambrose beer
said at the time that obviously the
family and their bereavement wanted to
make sure the son of a [ __ ] wouldn't
get up
but this was the this was robert's
inspiration for for his for his father's
final burial the pullman burial
um
fleetwood lindley then yeah
lindley was tracked down by a life
magazine reporter in 1963 he was 75
years old he was still living here in
springfield the reporter caught up with
him at st john's hospital he was about
to go in for gallbladder surgery and he
told his story to life magazine and
three days later the poor man died
he was the last person to look on the
face of abraham lincoln
this is a
wild and wonderful and often very weird
story but i think the part of it that
appeals to me the most
is the story of these ordinary guys in
springfield
who
kept this extraordinary secret i think
it's even more impressive in our own day
we live in a an age of of
of tell all um it's as if people can't
wait to publish a memoir in which
they'll completely humiliate themselves
and yet here are these here are these
guys who have
an incredible secret to keep and they
kept it for almost 25 years
thereby not only showing
what incredible integrity they had but
also protecting one of the most sacred
uh not going on on the limb here when i
say one of the most sacred relics in the
united states um washington is admired
but lincoln is loved
and uh
we have we owe a lot to the bank clerks
and the shopkeepers and the restaurant
and hotel clerks of springfield illinois
thank you very much
[Applause]
i'd be happy to answer questions
let me switch to the glasses but i can
see you
go ahead don't be shy
it's like playing stump the band come on
all right
yes
oh i'm sorry could
for the crew could you stand up and
they'll bring the boom over
it's all right
yes as far as we know there was uh um
john carroll power mentions a a rumor of
a plot in the early in the mid 1860s
late 1860s
some strange lawyer in in springfield
supposedly wanted to steal the body and
carry it to mexico
but supposedly he was a confederate
sympathizer um
but power wouldn't wouldn't give away
the name wouldn't say who this man was
he said that he died shortly thereafter
uh
and nobody's ever been able to track
down
whether the story is true there's
there's no record of it anyplace else no
no
sign of a rumor in any of the
springfield newspapers um i got one of
our one of our local historians molly uh
kennedy one of our local researchers to
try and track it down
and even she couldn't find it molly is
one of those people who can find
anything but apparently this is the only
time that lincoln
an attempt was made on lincoln's body
yes fred you had
i was
curious i just came back on a trip in
washington where i got an opportunity to
see kennedy's grave site as well as
washington's and
started me thinking how are some of our
other presidents buried do you have any
information on that or
oh it's a it's a most of it is fairly
traditional um
george washington is in is in a
sarcophagus in a in a little mausoleum
on mount vernon um interestingly in the
1830s there was an attempt to steal some
of his bones
his nephew
had fired one of the gardeners at mount
vernon and the gardener thought that you
know he had been unjustly dismissed and
came back in the middle of the night and
went into broke into the family tomb and
grabbed a couple of bones which he
thought was george's they weren't um
george and martha were in lead caskets
there was no you know there were no
bones lying around the ground and the
guy was picked up in alexandria virginia
the very next day
but that was
most most of them are in-ground burials
there hasn't been any other attempt as
far as i know on another president
john scott harrison the son of
benjamin harrison and the father of
william henry harris and his body was
stolen and sold to a medical school in
cincinnati for dissection
but it was found
before
the med students got to it
but otherwise i think this is the the
lincoln case is pretty unique
i guess on that macabre note
thank you very much
[Applause]
thomas crogwell's stealing lincoln's
body he's also author of saints behaving
badly and the wisdom of the popes for
more on his work visit belknap harvard
at hup.harvard.edu
[Music]